les drapeaux vicas les échafaudages les
ministres qui piétinent dans la colle la
musique du 325e régiment sous-marin qui
couvre les derniers bruits de marteau
les rattrapage de dernière minute avec
des bouts de ficelle des presque sûr
calicots tout cela est bien de tradition
française
il s'agisse d'un comice agricole du
vernissage du salon des femmes diderot
pic ou de l'inauguration de la grande
salle des fêtes du tout paris sait tout
comme ce soir au club saint germain il
en est presque de même à la seule
exception que les ministres sont restés
dans leur lit les musiciens jouent dans
les copeaux les femmes du monde ce sont
des vanités des nuages de fumée de
plâtre à tandis que les techniciens de
la radio le dos zébré de jolis du
guermeur de peinture fraîche l'orchestré
joue quand même mal gré le piano pas
accorder commune se doit dans un club
qui se respecte
l' orchestre c'est celui d'hubert folles
auxquelles s'est joint django reinhardt
quel est le premier morceau que vous
allez interpréter jango dream of you eh
bien nous vous écoutons
on
le
comment
on
m
on va l'aider
nous
le faut
dans
non
m
mais lors des 3 continue il a été
évidemment appelé comme il se doit par
un public qui a goûté la musique nous
devons entendre qu'elle est le morceau
qui suit c'est la poussée des
conventions d'être jaloux et je crois
que c'est lequel il tient le public
elle
mais
m
la tâche
la fin
le
non
ah oui
maman
non
oui
m
apport dans le monde
mais bon
m
oh
un peu
on
oh
elle a
bon
m
non
et
nous vous rappelons que celle orchestra
hubert folle avec django reinhardt qui
j'ai interprété ce morceau qui est très
applaudie par un public qui ne se lasse
pas d'entendre le processus guitariste
mais maintenant pour que nous ne venions
dans les plâtres à que nous soyons à
travers une marée de décoration nouvelle
il faut certainement que le club ait
changé d'aspect il a changé d'aspect
certes puisque je des colonnes
principales qu'il décorait ont sauté ou
plutôt qu'il décorait c'est une phrase
qui ne convient pas tout à fait qui je
n'ai plus tôt la visibilité de la scène
ont sauté maintenant que tout est
nouveau et nous allons demander aux
décorateurs du club saint-james 1 du
nouveau club saint germain des prés dans
quelles fonctions fin de quelle manière
il a confié nouvelle décoration et bien
nous avions plusieurs problèmes réseau
nous nous trouvons dans une cave par
conséquent il fallait d'abord combattre
l'humidité pour ça nous avons arrosé
abondamment les murs et le plafond avec
une sulfateuse malheureusement il reste
encore quelques uns qui sont assez sec
ensuite nous avons à combattre est
claustrophobie compréhensible dans une
cave alors nous avons entouré tous les
murs de barrières et le persiennes et
comme il fallait donner une certaine
chaleur à l'atmosphère nous avons mis
les formes art de partout nous attendons
maintenant la livraison du sérum molette
pour la famille draps qui entoure les
murs n'est ce pas et à ce moment là nous
mettrons des portraits de famille qui
permettra tous les manques du club et
tous les auditeurs qui voudront bien
célébrer des premières communions des
mariages etc
dans cette pièce on va ce qui ne
manquera pas d'être tout à fait charmant
mais c'est pas suffisant ou encore max
miracle à ces spectacles familiaux
il y en aura d'autres qui concerne le
cabaret décès de cabaret des sexes
on voudrait justement avoir quelques
précisions sur son activité nous avons
demandé à monsieur robin nous en parler
cette initiative a pour but d'amener le
public à participer à la recherche de
programmes nouveaux chaque semaine la
direction du club saint germain des prés
père présentera au s'efforcera de
présenter des attractions complètement
inédite regroupant des talents inconnus
méconnus ou incompris
cette entreprise permettra aux
directeurs de cabaret d'apprécier
l'accueil réservé à ces attractions par
un public
informer et spécialisés nous espérons
que cette entreprise aura le plus grand
succès mais est-ce que l'activité du
club se vendra strictement à ces
présentations
non il y aura aussi la présentation au
titre d'avant-premières de spectacles
déjà monté et déjà choisi déjà retenue
par des cabarets sera une sorte de
d'inauguration de vernissages et de
tests sur le public et pourriez vous
nous citer un spectacle qui démarrera
prochainement justement suivant cette
formule est bien le 5 mars nous allons
essayer de présenter un spectacle qui
s'appellera vraisemblablement le
spectacle de la réalité et qui sera une
chose à ces nouvelles et ce spectacle
sera composé d'un quels éléments de
d'artistes très peu connu et même de
nouveaux artistes
basée sur la réalité même au lieu
d'inventer des situations je les ai
prises puis que c'est moi qui suis
l'auteur de ce spectacle je les ai
prises dans la réalité dans la vie
quotidienne dans le fait divers est est
ce que cela sera illustrée de chansons
de musique ou est-ce que simplement
d'aider et sketches dramatique jouer le
plus nul de la manière la plus possible
la plus nue possible c'est à dire la
plus réelle la plus réaliste
il n'y aura pas de musique il y aura
simplement des pantomimes sur des faits
divers
il vient nous espérons que nos auditeurs
se rendront très très souvent club saint
germain avec cette nouvelle formule est
toute façon nous espérons au cours des
missions suivantes vous présenter la
retransmission de ces spectacles qui
auront lieu au club saint germain des
prés à quelle heure à peu près face sera
le spectacle que nous aurons
probablement entre 11h30 et 00h30 leur
habituel des spectacles avec abba de ces
jeunes talents inconnus méconnu pas
assez connus qui mérite de l'être plus
il en existe un grand nombre est un des
meilleurs à mon avis est certainement
robert namias revient à dire ce que j'ai
à côté de maille qui va nous interpréter
un des sketches qu'il passera
prochainement justement au club saint
germain ce sketch est intitulée hommage
comme c'est bien curieux à robert namias
ce qui montre une modestie quand même
dans le regard c'est tout à fait ça bon
gars va nous vous payer 2
nous en parler mais en fait c'est pas un
monologue c'est une réponse à une lettre
demoiselle antinéa à vous avez donné des
lectures vraiment tracer un terrain de
nîmes de pierre benoit à ben oui et qui
me dit qu'il me demandait quels
souvenirs pensez vous laisser lorsque
vous aurez disparu alors vous avez
laissé un souvenir qui est le petit
texte qui suggère encore l'essai mais je
crois que les sur important bond à parce
que vous allez partir bientôt moi
j'espère que nous offre le plus tard
possible
ah bon on va presser pour de bon en
attendant votre défunte la filiation
vous savez comme souvenir tous les
auteurs et de devenir classique puis
auteur d'une opérette ce passage est au
courant non pas du tout enfin continuer
et ben moi à moi aussi comme disait
catherine de russie c'est un sujet sur
lequel j'aime m'éteindre il arrive
parfois de songer à l'époque où je serai
installé en pièces détachées dans les
manuels de littérature
on verra mais oeuvres complètes mes
morceaux choisis comme ils disent
on choisit parkinson demande normale
quand même gênant surtout quels morceaux
et choisiront enfin je ferai le besoin
des bouquinistes ça sera la gloire de
matches je serai pas là pour voir tout
ça manon vous serez mort remarquez
j'avais des obsèques nationales avec
discours et cérémonie une rue portera
mon un boulevard peut-être j'ai de la
chance une façon de métro si je suis
grattée ne s'est pas la même chose donc
ce qui m'émeut vraiment c'est de penser
que ce sera inscrit au programme du
baccalauréat au certificat d'études tout
au plus quand même non on imagine très
bien les professeurs du lycée et boris
vian un seul lycée condorcet de nos
musées de dissertation et leurs élèves
commenté cette pensée de robert namias
l'enfant à une pression de
multiplication de l'homme parce moitié
je vous laisse rêveur
et puis à ceux qui sont en fait les par
ma faute de kim en voudront y sera
arriver là il aura confiance sur deux
vous aurez questionné sur jean anouilh
et serait bien marché et puis ils ont
interrogé sur moi mais n'aurait pas su
dire que l'été adepte de mon premier
roman remarqué je peux pas leur en
vouloir je n'ai pas encore écrit
mais viendra j'espère magique au rebond
mais le professeur aurait été agacé pas
voyons l'avenir sera votre programme
mais savez vous de lui ou est il né
quand il commence à faire de la radio
bah il a commencé en 1800 1900 vous avez
pas assez bien devant merci aux examens
quand on vous remercie c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de coiffes et les pour le garçon
passent leurs vacances à munir à
m'apprendre parker et à me dire mon nom
ça fait mal mais je crois qu'on commence
à vous me dire tout de suite ça va vous
faire des misères et cyan et puis
l'armée biographie une foule de gens je
ne connais pas encore mais que me
connaîtront sur le bout du doigt comme
s'il m'avait fait d'écrire ma vie mon
oeuvre mon personnage
c'était diront-ils un homme assez
quelconque
tout à fait oui un peu mieux p bon mari
mais ça je crois qu'il s'en prend at oui
le ce moment déjà mais ma femme que
j'aurais épouse il ya 30 ans ne sera
jamais démentir ce pur mensonge et le
raffut d'ailleurs toute publicité
tapageuse pour se réfugier dans le culte
de mon souvenir mon bureau travaillera
été transformée en musée et aucun objet
n'aurait caterina de sa place depuis la
mort au contraire même une pipe de ma
femme aura placé une une pipe de bruyère
l'aventuré par lorient oui c'est bien ça
sent un peu le truc et mes souvenirs des
femmes à s'attacher à des bibelots
représentatif même s'ils ne sont pas
authentiques
oui d'accord et tous les ans un des deux
suisses une délégation de jeunes lycéens
viendra visiter ce temple à cette
occasion la femme montrera l'album les
mots célèbres et lille ira entre autres
je ne peux pas y croire parce que
j'aurai prononcé à l'enterrement jean
paul sartre après tout il ya le reste
une de mes répliques à succès qui serait
passé en proverbes et croyez-vous des
fera beau demain nous assez émouvant que
j'aurais prononcer sur mon lit de mort
oui lorsqu'il m'arrive de songer à tout
ça je me sens profondément ému on dit
aussi c'est très gentil de compatir et
bien me resservir n'a bien je crois que
c'est un chef qui pourra plaire au plus
grand nombre d'auditeurs et voilà tous
ceux qui viendront applaudir le
spectacle du club saint germain des prés